meine damen des flughafen meine lieben
freunde wir spielen heute gemeinsam
battlefield 2042 was die nächste
generation von ego shootern es können
bis zu 128 spieler auf neuen konsolen
und pcs miteinander zocker es gibt zudem
modernste waffen und fahrzeuge
beispielsweise roboter hunde drohnen
oder wings und zudem gibt es auch noch
drei epische multiplayer erlebnisse und
zwar einmal urlaub warfare battlefield
ersatz und battlefield porto wo wir uns
unser eigenes battlefield mit eigenen
regeln erstellen können verlud und ich
haben uns vorab bereits importe bilder
einige spielerlebnisse erstellt die wir
gleich zocken werden allerdings könnt
ihr auch einfach selber immer ein
bisschen umschauen und vielleicht bei
dem einen oder anderen mitglied der
battlefield community findet ihr ja
schon ein spiel was euch da ein bisschen
zu sagt wo ihr selber bauzäunen
nicht direkt ein das will ich jetzt gar
nicht ich finde allerdings sagen dass
ich jetzt erstmal die highlights von
piloten und mir
was für modus spielen wir gerade lukas
team deathmatch wollte erst mal fragen
ob wir einfach die ganze zeit hier
stellen wir uns hier einfach die schönen
grafiken
ja ich bin ich bin dafür dass wir nach
vorne wir müssen an die front okay
ich bleibe hier hat mich schon gefragt
was das hierfür modus das ist ein modus
den ich tatsächlich selber erstellt habe
im neuen portal
ich habe ich habe ein
ich habe mir jetzt gebe ich bin durch
wir spielen hier gerade team deathmatch
mit 16 gegen 16 leuten auf der map
kaleidoskop und diesen modus habe ich
tatsächlich selber erstellt in diesem
portal modus können uns nämlich in
eigene welten stürzen die wir selber
vorher im browser erstellt haben und
hier es ist jetzt etwas relativ normal
ist noch die spiele gerade ganz normal
team deathmatch also 16 16 uns
gegenseitig eliminieren so wie viel hast
du jetzt ich hab ein
also wir spielen jetzt gerade hier ganz
normales team deathmatch wir werden
allerdings gleich auch noch eine etwas
andere runde zocken und zwar habe ich
keine munition mehr
wollen wir ein krieg wettbewerb machen
wir starten von hier wer schneller ist
okay die art der spur ist man hier neben
dem auto ja komplett leg dich hin ja und
dann lauft bis hierhin 32
naja und gesagt das ist
schon ein paar sekunden später der
unterschied nicht gut aus mit einer hp
anzeige ja ich war gerade im busch sehe
ich nicht ich sehe ich stehe doch jeder
weg neben bier hallo
hochklettern oder so kann man nicht wir
können aber hier immer ordentlich ein
paar leute töten da hinten zum beispiel
habe ich direkt beim zweiten kind
manchmal einmal hierüber wir sollten sie
flankieren was bin im krieg valuten ja
ich hab zwar ich kann hier nicht das ist
das ist hier nicht das letzte video was
wir zusammen auch noch mal mist addario
gewesen vor sieben jahren ich bin tot
luca wiederhold ich bin ich bin komplett
weg nebel so ich doch ich bin ich bin ja
also wir beiden das hier ja wir legen
dabei laufen gut ich bin lege ich wollte
ich wieder beleben dem defibrillator
vorlagen vermuten und ich auch die an
karneval um so freunde wir befinden uns
jetzt war also der andere andere wird
das vielleicht schon direkt erkennen
immer noch ob der gleichen map
allerdings seht ihr schon unten links
auf der karte dass dieser bereich da
vorne jetzt abgesperrt ist und das heißt
wenn ich hier vorne jetzt wirklich
irgendwie mal ganz kurz über die brücke
laufe und mit diesem roten bereich zu
sehern ehre dass ich eine warnung
bekommen von wegen zurück ins
kampfgebiet dann heißt das diese map
jetzt deutlich verkleinert wurde dass
sie daran dass wir uns jetzt gerade ein
neues portal erstellt haben und zwar
geht es hier darum dass wir uns nicht
mit ganz vielen leuten team deathmatch
spielen auf dieser map sondern eine
kleinere version dieser karten spielen
und
nicht so schlecht war ein clip also ich
hab einfach ein schuss von ch ein paar
abens
sorry aber ich habe nur eine
bohrmaschine und raketenwerfer dann hast
du überhaupt mit bohrmaschine was hast
du denn gerade so bei dir im inventar
können zumindest noch mehr leute ich
habe eine kleine pistole
ich habe einen bunsenbrenner haben einen
raketenwerfer und ich habe eine granate
das ist allerdings jetzt nicht so stark
dass die das gesagt habe weil damit nur
ja ich gerade meine taktik denn meine
taktik sieht wie folgt aus
ich sehe ich nicht wirklich auch nicht
immer was soll das denn jetzt wir sind
im krieg vermuten ich habe es gesagt
wieso patrick kommt
ich warte hier auf dich hab' mir kleine
torte gebastelt hier rechts sieht aus
wie linda sich geburtstag hat ja
ich bin informiert zehn stunden später
hallo
als ich mich mit dem raketenwerfer
getroffen
nee das war meine wunderkerzen das war
ja mein geschichte die ich das ist aber
auch traurig dass du das nie so richtig
werde ich dann eine freude machen möchte
na ja aber ich bin gebrandmarkte skin
ich weiß das eine mal als als wir im
klub war das tut mir die torte ins
gesicht gedrückt aber man kann ja ich
höre die ganze zeit schritte erklärt
kyra also dieser gruppe
haben wir uns gegenseitig getötet
ich hab dich umgebracht und mich hallo
und ich mache jetzt 1 1 gegen 18 mal
hinten sogar schon wir machen ihr vater
war da das müssen wir jetzt natürlich
ständig zu der zuständig hier zu dieser
palme ok dazu der zu der rechten ja
das ist keine palma das jetzt passieren
das ist keine palme das ist die palme
enders ist eine puk aktie haben wir
wollen wir spielen hier gerade einen
portal modus auch super dass jetzt
gerade erst erklären wo wir schon die
ganze zeit drin wenn aber wir uns leider
ein bisschen ablenken lassen wir spielen
gerade ein portal modus bei dem es ein
bisschen witziger hergeht wir spielen
jetzt nämlich nicht 16 16 team
deathmatch relativ klassik auf einer
großen web sondern auf einer etwas
kleineren map dass sie dir hier schon
und wir spielen hier eine etwas
abgespeckte version sag ich mal ihr seht
es schon anhand der waffen hier und ich
habe mir nun und pistole ich habe ihm
einen bunsenbrenner raketenwerfer um
eine granaten sind sogar schon leer
allerdings hat alle ja auch nicht ganz
aber ich denke du kommst jetzt jeden
moment nicht weiß nicht wo du bist ich
schieß mal kurze
ja die schüsse sind extrem weit weg nach
20 jahren kamen dann auch mal an und das
battle konnte beginnen so bleibt setzt
hier an der obersten stufe stehen und
ich gehe hier auf die linie und jetzt
gehen wir in die schleife die dings
position hier ja
jetzt lange gedauert mit chemischen und
jetzt auch war dann bald los geht's mit
meiner lieben freunde oben sind
bohrmaschine du hast das ist keine
bohrmaschine natürlich ist es die
bohrmaschine das hat auch fettes ding
auf verrücken kleben
das ist mein
damit machst jetzt nichts falsches
wir mal rein
der ablauf hier meine beim bund
er wehrt wenn das volk hält sich
[Musik]
gegenwärtig mit einer bohrmaschine
wurden dabei getötet eigentlich wollte
ich an der stelle das video hier schon
beenden die sache ist allerdings dass
mit piloten dann unbedingt so sein
defibrillator zeigen wollte hallo na na
siehst du da an hast
naja vielen dank ja ja ich habe dich
haben in schwarz habe ich die anderen
braunau jan heiß was ist das hier ja das
ist mein haus das ist ein haus ja ich
wohne hier da kann ich mich hinsetzen
und wenn ich schlafe dann lege ich mich
hier so hin und
was was können die sachen wie gesagt
dass diesmal ein wäscheständer hier
rechts
und
war ziemlich kalt hier leben acht
perfekt
[Musik]
ich muss hier ganz normal war mein haus
zeigen sich gerade gebaut und dann werde
ich dir den wirten defibrilator
wiederbelebt
möglich dass heute videos allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch battlefield 2042 mit mir luca und
puten gefallen hat dann das gern einen
daumen hoch unter dem video abonniert
main kanal und klickt auf die glocke
damit den weiteren videos nicht verpasst
das spiel kommt am 19 november raus also
checkt auf jeden fall gerne die info box
ab dort findet ihr einen link und ihr
findet euch auch einen link zur lutens
video eingeblendet also wenn ihr sehen
wollt wie wir vermuten skandal auch so
ein bisschen das spiel getestet haben
dann steckt das auch gern ab und findet
selbst wahrscheinlich doch auch die kurz
eingeblendet wenn ihr genau die gleichen
szenarien spielen wollten die wir uns
importe bilder erstellt haben
sie könnte sich legen dass punkten video